exciting
[Music]
regulating short-term rentals is the
goal of a bill that's making its way
through the legislature now the proposal
would impose state rules and taxes on
properties that are rented out through
companies like airbnb
some are all for it others say though it
is a bad move
sasha loftus joining us now live near
rancho and oki with what the proposed
changes could mean
sasha
denise as you can see this neighborhood
like so many across the las vegas valley
is peaceful
and quiet but those who live here worry
this bill could just really turn things
upside down so they're asking lawmakers
to consider
other options we're hurt and frustrated
laura mcswain says she's concerned for
the future of her home
we're really really nervous about what
the impact of this is going to be on our
neighborhood
mcneeley states near rancho and oakley
is safe and quiet
but mcswain worries a bill moving
through the nevada legislature
could change that it puts an additional
level of compliance on top of
what they've got ab 363 would establish
rules enforcement guidelines and taxes
part of this
is really to enforce compliance along
that
lines so that the jurisdiction knows
who's got short-term rentals experts say
the bill
which proponents call a step in the
right direction
would allow another level of regulation
we just feel like if we'd have been
invited into the conversation sooner
a there wouldn't be the level of
frustration but mcswain believes
it wasn't thought through as it could
allow more rental properties in one
place
and override a city ordinance many
prefer
it allows us to have continuity with our
neighbors you know because we do have an
owner there present
on the property that's why she's asking
lawmakers to reconsider
and understand what this change could
mean for
everyone the thing that i think that
they should consider is the fact that we
weren't considered
now ab363 which was introduced by
assemblywoman rachelle nguyen
back in march has not gone yet to a vote
through the assembly or the senate we
will of course keep you posted as it
progresses through the legislature
reporting live in las vegas tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now